Is it okay for someone with a cancer that has the size of the liver to try the blood
weight protocol?
So it's typically okay for anybody to try the blood weight protocol at any time unless
your driver is dairy, that could be an issue.
But even if your driver is dairy and you stayed up a dairy up to this point and now you're
thinking about trying the blood weight protocol because your cancer is growing, there's nothing
wrong with that.
If you feel like you want to give the blood weight protocol a try, now if you don't know
what the blood weight protocol is for other people that are listening, it's a mixture
of cottage cheese and flaxseed oil and you blend that up with the diversion blenders.
And that's the blood weight protocol.
Now there's a recipe for it and we have that on our website, on a blog post, we just
looked at it up.
But yeah, it certainly has some challenges as far as taste to begin with but if you give
it by that, we've seen some hazardous results with it so I'd say absolutely, you can give
it a try.